[Music]
welcome to diversity and leadership
connect with community
today's actually this session
specifically is focused on our veterans
club happy veterans day to everybody
out there we hope you are having a
wonderful day and celebration and thank
you for
your service my name is will torres i'm
one of the admission officers here at
the stanford graduate school of business
thrilled to present um this panel i
think these are some of the folks
who really give so much nuance
and uh to the community and so with that
i'd like to turn it over to do some
brief introduction
introductions so if you could start with
a
name uh what branch of the military you
came from
and what made you wanna go to business
school to begin with
so maybe mikko if we could start with
you please
hi everyone my name is nico i was in the
navy for seven
years i was a submarine officer based
out of
connecticut for most of my time and for
me
what i was looking for at a business
school was a way that i could carry for
the leadership skills that i gained in
the military
and pivot directly into the business
world
awesome thank you um jarrell how about
you
hi everyone my name is jerome mendoza
and
i am in the army i'm actually
still in i'm active duty and i'll be
returning to
the military after this and one of the
reasons why i decided to go to business
school this time is to
uh one be able to kind of take a break
and to like explore some
uh options for potential uh
like pretty much post-military uh
options
great thank you nate how about you
yeah hi everyone i'm nate hetchcock i'm
an nba 2
here at the business school i'm also
active duty army like jerrell
coming up on a decade of service for
both of us here and i came to
uh the business school because i'm
headed back to the united states
military academy to be a professor
uh and so some of the finance and some
of the skills that i'm learning here at
the business school be applicable as i
go to teach
uh future officers of the united states
army
and then austin if you round out the
panel please hi everybody my name is
austin i am the only nba one here
uh i was a an army helicopter pilot uh
like nate
and as far as what i was looking for in
business school parallels very much with
what nico said but part of it was
uh you know looked at having some of the
leadership skills from the army
uh but if you stuck a balance sheet in
front of me i was pretty useless and so
um part of why mba and why stanford was
to shore up some of those deficiencies
to be able to move forward and
and be dynamic uh in the next chapter
in business yeah so we'll we'll come
back to this idea of
continuing to develop some of the
leadership
capacities um and competencies that you
were using in service but let's start
with a little bit about the vets club
so nico you're one of our leaders can
you talk a little bit about your role
and then about the vets club
so i am one of two co-presidents of the
veterans club
and i would say we are a very small
tight-knit community on the campus and i
think that's one of the things that
makes us distinct when
you consider other business schools
because we we tend to be on a smaller
end
as a percentage of the overall class so
for us it's
it's a very interesting um dynamic where
we have most of our classmates that have
very little uh interaction with military
and their previous work
and so we are the ones that are kind of
the ambassadors
if you will that is able to bridge the
gap between the military and the
civilians
and you know we're small enough where we
can kind of like also
socialize and talk about our transition
from the military to the civilian so we
we almost are like a support group and
help each other out in that manner as
well
and then can um can someone talk a
little bit about some of the events
um that the vets club has hosted
recently
uh yeah i can i can tackle that um you
know
i'd say like nico said it's a really
unique club uh
and i'd say one of the benefits is that
even
if you're not super active i'm i'm not
super active in the club but even if
you're not super active
everybody knows everybody and so
even the small events that we'll do so i
think every year we do a veterans
retreat
um you know some of this has been kind
of hindered by covid
but even some of the small events that
we'll do usually like when we got when
we first got here last year on campus
there was a veteran's day like a
veteran's barbecue
um the vets retreat itself there's all
kinds of
different small weekend groups and stuff
that you'll see and so
i think that and niko can tag on with
any other big events but those are the
big ones that you'll see
i know we also do the lpf's that
that are so famous here at stanford um
which is
a liquidity preference function for
those uh not familiar with that acronym
uh where everybody kind of gets together
and has a drink so i think you'll see
that we we do a lot of things
but mostly it's very family oriented is
how i would describe it
just because of the size that nico
mentioned
so austin curious from your perspective
as
uh our mba won on the panel how have you
seen
how the vets club supported you and your
transition to campus
yeah that's a it's a really poignant
question well i actually showed up here
on crutches
uh with two broken feet on september 4th
uh and i had kind of half baked
the idea of how i was going to get my
things up to my room
um and so rather than my poor fiance
trying to carry some heavy furniture i
literally sent a note out in the vets
thread and about 10 minutes later
there were 10 vets uh in their sos
just in the parking lot that helped me
unload the truck uh people i
didn't know me from adam i mean it was
literally day one of showing up
and and and they were out in spades um
so i i think to get to nate's you know
family
you know that that's a community that um
you know one thing i think that all of
us are really sensitive to
is particularly you know nate and
jerrell are headed back but
but for someone like nico or someone
like me um there's definitely concerns
about losing that sense of community
when you leave the military
and there is so much continuity not only
within the bats club but i think the
broader stanford community at large
but that's just one small example i mean
i i just asked for a favor
and people were there like that um and
that was such an
awesome way uh to start my mba
experience um
just just to know that i had people that
had my back from from day one and i was
really grateful for that
and then so thinking about that nico
what
what inspired you to leadership within
this group specifically
i i think austin brought it uh very
succinctly together is like i just
wanted to keep the
family the sense of family and belonging
together going forward
and i know that um given
our small size as a club it really takes
a concerted effort
and so i felt motivated based off the
the veterans that came before us who put
a really good
club together and i think especially um
you know for most of us in the club
we're transitioning
and there's a lot of ground that we feel
like we have to cover
because we we come up to school and some
of us are not
familiar you know the difference between
like a corporate finance role and
private equity
so for us we want to make sure that we
have this community where we can help
each other out
and and learn some of the things that
maybe our civilian counterparts don't
have to necessarily go through
yeah and i oh sorry go ahead yeah hey
well i
just wanted to so to niko's point you
know jerrell and i
sometimes since we we essentially don't
have this
uh you know we kind of have a certain
future we know that our
uh what our employment's gonna be next
um i forget about some of the awesome
things that the vets club does
outs uh to help set you up for work um
and so
one of the things i think that just went
on or is going on here in the next week
or just went on last week
um was a what we call vets trek
uh where the vets club gets a bunch of
people together
and they go to places like this last one
was at facebook i believe
they go to facebook and they meet with
people so from that employment
perspective those are some other
really big events that the vets club
will be able to do
and quite frankly they have those
connections because it's vets
at the companies here in the in the
valley
that have those uh the connections and
they they're willing to bring vets in so
not always as applicable for me or
jarrell but that's another thing that to
nico's point of
as you transition another thing that i
think the vets club does a great job of
uh from like someone that doesn't
necessarily have to worry about that
perspective
yeah actually nate and jerrell if we can
stay on that topic for a little bit
um going from military
to business school and then back to
military
you mentioned a little bit about the why
but can you tell us a little bit more
about
how you see some of the lessons from
business school being applicable within
the military context
yeah i can take that um so for me uh
it's actually it has a lot of connection
um
especially with the job i'm going to
before so in the army i was
a signal officer which is mostly
communications and it management
and so a lot of like the soft skills
definitely play a role in
how effective you are in your job but
i'm actually transitioning over to the
acquisitions core which is more of the
business arm
and so a lot of the processes especially
for some of the technical things like
procurement and then even like
contracting
and bidding are really important and i
think uh
those are some of the classes that i'm
looking to try to do just to get some of
my
you know some of my feet wet to to kind
of figure that out because
we do deal with a lot of civilian um
industries and and companies at least in
the job that i'm going to be going into
so i thought this was like a perfect
stepping stone
to kind of get more experience in the
institutional realm before i actually
have to practice it
yeah i'll add all that one thing to
girls point i i think
um so there's this awesome class here
that if if you guys end up coming i
would highly recommend called leadership
perspectives
um some of the guests that attend this
are people like the ceo of yahoo marissa
meyer
the 20th google employee uh general
mattis
was a guest speaker i was just on class
last night and
we were going through this woman's
leadership philosophy and she said you
know
what i realized is that there's only one
business you're ever going to be in and
that's the business of people
right um and that's what the army uh
essentially is in the military is just
like i mean our technology is great
everything
but it really is the business of people
and stanford's focus
on leadership and and how to interact
and deal with the business of people
is uh i mean it's second to none there's
so many classes that you can learn
some of these soft skills as long as as
well as the analytic skills that you
need to go work at a consulting firm or
anything else but these soft skills
are going to help you be a better leader
and so i think for me going back
to the army to leading troops you know
that that
that experience and those kinds of
perspectives is going to be you know
what i take with me
yeah not to put you on the spot nate but
maybe maybe to put you on the spot
is there a particular element of that
interpersonal um kind of dynamic
that uh was almost like an aha moment
for you or something that
made you step back and think huh you
know
how am i approaching this like any any
insights there
yeah i'd say uh i'd say that there's two
classes
uh in particular again here uh one i
have not taken yet it's actually called
interpersonal dynamics i think
nico mentioned he's taken it uh it's
otherwise known as touchy-feely and it's
literally a class that is known all
throughout the business community if you
have any sort of stanford ties um i have
not taken that class yet but
close second to that is one of our first
classes called lead labs
um where you you really do start to
learn about
how you what how you you know how
sometimes what you mean to say in the
way that you mean to lead
uh doesn't necessarily affect people the
way that you expect
and as a as an army officer like your
soldiers are never going to come up to
you and be like hey
boss that's not the way that that came
off on me but i think in this
environment
i've really learned that and that you
you have to consider the perspective
from which your soldiers or from which
the people that you're leading are
really considering you and you have to
actively seek that feedback and i think
that we learned that
a lot in leadership or not leadership
perspectives but in um
in lead labs and so i think that first
quarter as early as first quarter of nba
one
i was having those kinds of aha moments
where like okay man maybe
maybe this isn't the right way to lead a
group of people or maybe maybe you need
to think about things a little
differently
yeah thank you austin um
nba1 uh are you in lead labs currently
i am can you tell us about a little bit
about the experience from someone who's
like actively in the
in the course yeah absolutely i i think
nate hit you know
the key highlight right um and and one
of the things that's important for us
is um there's no doubt that we are
branded differently
as as soldiers sailors marines and
airmen than our some of our peers
um and so one of the things that's been
helpful
is okay what are some of those things
that make me different that are either
you know multipliers or or detractors
uh you know one for example is i asked
my lead lab squad it's
six people with whom you get really
intimately close
i said hey if i use any military jargon
or things that you don't understand
call me out on it um and it was really
kind of a checking mechanism to see that
hey there are a lot of things that i use
i use the expression last week flash to
bang
to describe something that was happening
quickly and um
you know i had one of my one of my
colleagues grabbed me after classes hey
what did that mean um and so it's really
great to kind of be
vulnerable a little bit um and as nate
you know as eloquently mentioned
you're getting that on the spot feedback
that hey here's the message i was trying
to send
was it received in that way and how did
it make you feel um
and and then so you've got the
opportunity to kind of adapt and
overcome
uh from some of these challenges um and
to really grow
and i found myself growing exponentially
through that actually this morning
we were doing kind of our conclusion
feedback and it was so
fascinating to hear from each of the
five other members of my squad
uh provide feedback say hey here's what
you did well here's what i'd love to see
from you and
here's how you inspired me uh and every
answer was different and all of it was
so useful so
i think that class is particularly
helpful and like nate
uh and some others uh i i am aspiring to
take touchy-feely too for those same
reasons because i think it really builds
off of
what you learn in lead labs and i think
if i can finally that the stanford brand
right is
touchy feely right if you think about
what differentiates stanford
i think it's really that focus on the
emotional
aspect of leadership and i don't think i
ever
understood and i'm still learning how
important that is
to being a good leader and that's
something that we get really right here
i think
so it seems like the interpersonal
dynamics
is a common theme that we're revolving
around here
so actually can we hear a little bit
more about the class from someone who's
in it so
nico you mentioned uh you took it
previously jarel have you taken it
okay so maybe mikko could you please
tell us a little bit about the course
as austin says interpersonal dynamics
really does build upon what
you learn in leadership labs and
leadership labs is a core requirements
everyone has to take leadership labs but
it's an elective
interpersonal dynamics as an elective
and i have found out that
um you know what nate has said when
you're leading
in the military you're never really
gonna get a subordinate to come up to
you and be like
um sir ma'am i you know
it did not you know that what you said
affected me in way x y and z
and being able to have a deep dive on
that in every personal
dynamics i found myself where i have
said something where i intended
to do x and then
a classmate of mine says that he or she
felt lie
and i was kind of like taken back and
then it allowed me
to have an open dialogue with them to
figure out you know
it could be down to like how i said it
the tone
if there was a way that like the body
language so these are things that i
could not
imagine in any other environment how i
would be able to learn this
and i really enjoy the experiential
learning that we get in interpersonal
dynamics
because it really it allows each
individual to find out
what they need to work on or and what
they are good at
in order to move forward
awesome so as we were talking a little
bit about classes
are there any other classes that you
found particularly
insightful useful thought-provoking
so maybe we can start with jarrell um
to put you on the spot welcome to cold
calling
no worries um i actually have two in
mind and they actually were
electives that i took last spring as an
nba one i was pretty lucky to take them
uh the first was reputation management
and that was with allison kluger and i
thought that was amazing to
um just one like take it like a look
back and
you know kind of self-assess like how
you perceive yourself but as also how
others perceive you
and it was really cool we did a project
a paper tour you actually surveyed
people in your class and like people
outside
um and you were able to like to write a
reflection paper on it and i thought
that was really interesting to see
especially over the years you can go as
far back as you wanted and i definitely
went
actually as far back from from like high
school and college
to try to get some of that perspective
to see how i've changed
and then the second one would be uh
diversity
diverse leadership which was actually a
co-led class for the education school
and again i think i'm huge on the
leadership and the soft skills because
again i think that's one of the most
important things you can learn
not only here but you can bring back to
the military in almost
any industry that you you go into and
that
uh actually helps too with your
leadership we had to write leadership
philosophy stories
and so we had to almost write some was
like a mini talk uh where you were able
to give about like a 10 minute
monologue as to like where you believe
you your leadership came from and where
you think you're going
and again i thought that type of
introspection and being able to kind of
like work with your classmates on that
was
super valuable and something i would
definitely want to take as i move
forward
nice anybody else
i can give him some perspective here
austin is
like just you know crushing through
uh poor guys just crushing through the
mandatory requirements right now so
uh i think the best people to answer
this question is probably niko and and
myself and darrell
um because once he makes it out of this
quarter and half of next quarter
uh he's really gonna his eyes are gonna
be opened up and he's gonna have so many
cool opportunities
uh look i mean stanford but the classes
here are phenomenal
um i mean not much else needs to be said
other than the guy that won the nobel
prize a few weeks ago works in the
business school
um one of them right he's a lecturer in
the business school so
i i think that you know one of the
classes that niko and i are in right now
is taught by a gentleman by the name of
keith hennessey any one of his classes
are phenomenal
uh he's known as being one of the best
uh professors at the business school
uh and by the way he happened to be the
economic advisor to george w
bush or uh yeah to george w bush so i
mean like there's just
there's so many classes right whether
it's um
and what i really love about the mba
program is that you can take a class
journal and i took a class
in sports business management both of us
were division one athletes in college
uh you know we took a class in sports
business management
uh at the same time you can be taking an
american policy class
uh there's just so much that you can do
here
um outside of your traditional business
roles but what's crazy is is all of them
uh just refine those leadership skills
and those skills of working with people
i think niko said before you before
everybody logged on
niko was saying that he never he uses
touchy feely and some of the skills he
learned there
um in one of the classes that we're in
together now one of key tennessee's
classes that we're in together now
he uses those skills more than he did in
touchy-feely in this class because
everything is just so parallel so you
know i
i'd say i challenge you to find a class
that isn't good
uh is what i would say it's a world's
question awesome thanks now that we can
get academics out of the way
let's actually shift gears to what's
probably really on people's minds and
we're gonna start jumping into the
the q and a box so let's
try i'll try to keep on a slightly
chronological track at first and then
from there we'll see where the
conversation takes us
so um as you were thinking
about you know different mba
programs um are there any tips for
how you translate some of the
unique military skills you've had like
during the application process
how did you approach that i know austin
you talked about
like jargon right now in your classes
but for the rest of you as well like
how are you thinking about translating
the cultures
yeah i i'd be happy to answer that first
will um
so i think a big part of it is just uh
reliance on the community
um you know given that today is is
veterans day i've had some really
thought provoking
uh conversations with classmates who you
know sent messages of support and just
kind of hey thanks for
thanks for sharing your story um and
i have found that i'm even more grateful
of my classmates that have been willing
to share their stories with me
um and i think that this is like a it's
a very symbiotic process
um and that your classmates are really
willing to pour into you
um as a part of the community here so as
you figure out okay
hey you know when i told my dad i was i
was getting out of the army
um it was because i got hurt and i
remember the first phone call i had with
him and he goes dude that's a bummer
what are you even good at um and he
will i see you laughing he was just kind
of you know he was he was yanking my
chain a little bit
but it was a great point and um you know
it's okay how do i shore up what my
skills are and translate those
and a big part of that translation
process
is learning from your classmates right
and it's saying
there is such a mixed bag here uh will
and
and the admissions gurus do such
a wonderful job of making a gsb salad
right there's not too much lettuce
there's not too much tomato
not you know you get the metaphor right
um but because that is done
so carefully no two mbas are the same
uh and by mbas i mean students and
everybody's got a unique and diverse
perspective to bring
so i have gotten really deep into the
bowels of just some
really authentic genuine deep
conversations with my classmates
that have taught me a lot about myself
and about what my you know passions
desires
and and aspirations are moving forward
um but
similarly have said hey could i see
myself doing
what someone else did or a role like
that
um and beginning to kind of hash out hey
what are my strengths what are my
weaknesses
and who do i expect to be 18 months from
now when nba graduation comes around
yeah and i would have to say as well and
i want to make sure that folks on this
call know
how much appreciation i have um so the
veterans club i know
uh nico's been part uh part of this as
well have been
helping us on the admissions side
understand
kind of what are some of the themes and
different
cultural elements there are within the
military and among the different
branches
so there's a lot of back and forth as
well with
our students helping us do a better job
to continue creating
you know the salad uh as austin
mentioned so thank you nico and all
and all of them your predecessors before
you for helping us do our job better
cool kind of along the same thread of
as we're thinking about business school
do any of you have recommendations on
how to prepare if admitted
so are there like particular courses or
topic areas
that either might have been helpful or
you think
could be helpful to make sure you hit
the ground running in the classroom yeah
i can i can quickly answer this i
i think that um
depending on how long you've been out of
school like i mean i had been out of
school for like eight years
prior to coming here so i i think and i
told i shared this view with austin when
him and i were talking before he
uh before he got in here uh
i think that you're just like you're
gonna feel a little bit behind the first
quarter i think if depending on how far
or how long but what i'd say is there's
there's so much help here and there's so
many people that want to see you succeed
um you know whether it's a professor
holding office hours or whatever i i
really think that it's not
a huge hurdle i i really don't think
that like
you know i don't know that you need to i
mean obviously you probably need to do
some stuff to prepare for the gmat and
and
score well on that and i think that if
you've done that stuff and and
and uh prepared for the gmat and that
kind of things i think when you get here
you'll see this is just my experience
but you'll see that there's so many
people willing to help
from nba twos willing to help nba ones
professors tas
there's a lot of people that are willing
to help get you back into that mindset
and after the first quarter i felt
very comfortable being back in an
academic
world is what i would say at least
that's my experience i don't know
i'll leave it open to the rest of the
panel nate you actually
bring up um so transition kind of into
another question here that
since we're on this track i really want
to dig into it um
starting business school like
that feeling of that you might be behind
has anybody tapped into some of these um
support resources
uh to help you in the classroom
like whether in the classroom or like
transitioning um to the
kind of business school culture
uh i can answer some of that and so
what's interesting is yeah i think
for me personally uh i know i talked to
nico and probably some of the other vets
but i i felt the struggle
at least in the beginning and um i think
it was again
hard being eight years out to just like
remember what it is like to
open a book and to have to go to class
multiple times and have homework and you
know
not just have a job where you you know
you can leave that work at home uh
working in the office and then like
instead of having homework uh
as soon as you get back and then also
trying to juggle that with all the
social events that we try to do
and i think some of the things that
i tapped into were definitely the
teachers and the faculty i think they're
like nate had said that they're more
than willing to help um
i know that we had and i'm not sure
actually
if the nba once had it this time but we
had like an autumn based level
tutor course program so they actually
were able to
on like certain days of the week uh they
would have tutors who were
mba twos who would help specifically
with the um
mandatory classes that they have which i
thought was really uh helpful because
especially if
you know depending on your time there's
like a huge block that you could just go
in and kind of like walk in whenever
and then i actually dealt with a lot of
um informal
and so again uh there's so many
classmates that you know
that are have been in the background of
finance or accounting
and you know just turning around hey
like i
literally didn't understand any of those
terms that just came out of his mouth
um can you help me with that uh people
are more than willing to do that even
over a coffee chat
and i think that's actually even to
where i got to meet a lot of my
classmates just
through that informal helping of like of
classes and then being able to get to
know them on that personal level
anybody else
uh i i would just to add something a
little bit different i would
when i think about transition and
preparing for school
i honestly have encouraged all of my
peers and
the year groups below me who
have been admitted and are wondering
what to do between
separation and coming in and i honestly
will advocate
there's a lot of administration that
comes with separating from the us
military
and at least in the navy you can't
separate
or you have to begin to process no
earlier than nine months out
and you i personally believe you really
do need that time
because there is a lot that you're not
familiar with and like trying to get
you know different areas of which branch
of military you are
in line with like where you're going to
school and all that like there's a lot
to deal with that
i know that some people because of the
timing they got caught up in that
and so anything you can do to prepare
yourself
i would say life administration wise
before you get here so you're not
dealing with everything the the humming
and the buzzing of gsb
and dealing with like separating from
the military it would be
a huge stress reliever in my opinion
i love the way you phrase it as life
administration
um for the other panelists any other
tips on like life administration
kind of as you transition to to your
school yeah i would say 100 nico has a
fantastic point um i i
again i pcs down here so i the army
moved me out here so i didn't have half
of the issues
that that niko had probably as he
transitioned out of the military
so i can't even imagine because i felt
overwhelmed the first two or three weeks
of
of there's like there's just so much
going on between academics and all the
social events and everybody getting to
know everybody
and your classmates are just these
wonderful people
i mean uh i think austin mentioned it
will will and his team do a great job
of finding like literally the best
people i mean there's olympic athletes
in our class
there's all kinds of incredible people
that come here and you want to get to
meet them
uh you will be overwhelmed and so rather
than
to take a college course uh or like a
community college course to refresh your
algebra or your
calculus if you think you need to do
that i would 100
drop that and just do what it takes to
be ready to start class on day one
and be ready to to go because the
program will when you get here the
program is is fast and furious the first
couple weeks and i think that mikko's
point is
cannot be emphasized enough like you
have to be here and have all that other
stuff
done so that you can just focus on on
what you're here to do
there's a couple so while we're still in
like the pre gsb
kind of realm timeline there are a
couple questions about gmat gre
that testing process um so just curious
when you were going through the process
do you have any like
tips or recommendations on like
different ways you might
approach it or kind of words of wisdom
for folks who are
heading into that part of their
preparation
yeah i'll start with that one because
that's uh that's fresh
fresh in mind for me um so
excellent question um and you know i
it was a question at the forefront of my
mind as well um
when i was sitting in your chairs uh
just just a short while ago
here's the bottom line guys the the gmat
and the gre both
suck and i'm sorry for for using that
term um but but it's a hurdle you have
to get over
right um and so part of that is
acceptance and just say hey here's this
mountain that i've got to climb over
um showing up at the last second and
trying to scale it is not helpful
um i took the gmat for the first time i
had some complication of my situation
but
i took the gmat for the first time on
january 31st
and i took it cold and it absolutely
kicked me six ways to sunday
um so it's it's a test that you've got
to have a lot of respect for
um it's just really challenging so the
best thing that you can do to set
yourself up for success is two things
one your scores are good for five years
so
if you're not thinking about applying
even this year and you're maybe thinking
oh i'm going to apply in a year or two
hey take it now um when you can focus
and optimize to be successful on that
test
that's going to help you because spoiler
alert you know the application
of itself is a beast right and so now
you're juggling potentially a full-time
military job
you're balancing applying to stanford
and any other institutions you want to
consider
uh and then you're you're balancing
getting ready and executing the gmat
um so in terms of techniques it's not
really a technique question i i just
start early right don't don't put it off
um
because it is it really is a unique
thought process
and it's just one of those things that
you have to do um
the other piece too there's everyone has
their own strategy and the best thing i
can offer you is find what works best
for you
whether it's self-paced online tutoring
that's asynchronous
whether it's hiring a tutor whether it's
reading a study book
um pick what works best for you and
stick with it
um you know everyone's gonna have a
different way in which they attacked it
so i don't think there's a silver bullet
a one size fits all approach but the
best council i give you is just
don't wait you've got to be diligent
make a plan for yourself
give yourselves a long runway and then
stick to it
thank you as we shift over into like now
you're here
like how have you started to navigate
like finding the right career fit
and and or recruiting and so this might
be geared more
towards some of our mba twos here
so how did you approach even thinking
about your summer internships maybe
i can take that one will because i
imagine nate and jerome might have an
untraditional path for there since
they're going back into the army
but um i i got on campus
and i felt like i i was faced with the
typical dilemma that most veterans are
it's
either look at investment banking or
consulting
and those are typically well suited for
veterans because it's very structured
very demanding
and the hours aren't necessarily
as comparable to what one would do in
the military
so in terms of like a stepping stone for
transition
that is usually what we were told and i
and i did consider those but at the end
i was
you know i was at the end of the day i
was like i'm at business school there's
so much more for me to discover
and so i started like reaching out and
so there was we have brown bag lunches
where we have different
communities uh industries companies that
come onto campus
and they give us like a 45-minute info
session and there's also
networking events and so i was
experiencing a little bit you know
branch out in finance and
realized that i really liked the
technical side since i was technically
in the submarine community but then i
also liked
you know where tech was going and so i
was
kind of quickly inundated with all these
little
all these different industries but
ultimately what i decided was
i really enjoyed leading people and
there aren't that many
fields directly at a business school
where you can continue to lead people
and what i found out and that's how i
came across
search funds which is very unique to
stanford
i'm happy to go into that a little bit
more but search funds essentially is the
quickest way
that an mba student can become a ceo of
a company
and at the end of the day that's i i
wanted to lead people i wanted to lead
an organization
and so that's what i ended up doing for
my summer and after graduation i intend
to
start a search fund on my own
[Music]
um speaking about that kind of discovery
phase
can folks talk a little bit about either
the career management center or
how you tap into the alumni network as
part of your your search
yeah actually i i can actually take this
one um
so the career management center is a
phenomenal again
not not one that i use often um
but the career management center is an
awesome place that has
uh a ton of things whether it's job
postings um
when you get here if you're interested
in doing uh so there's
one of three ways that you can fulfill
what's called our global exploration
requirement
one of which is to do an internship with
a foreign firm
for about four weeks again this process
was slightly changed because of covid
but uh
long story short is the career
management center and the career hub um
they'll they'll put on their uh
different events
or different uh different firms that
want to hire you
um and so you'll be able to go on
there's
look at your applications look at what
you want to do and you'll be able to
find a lot of different things so i
think that that's
fantastic um i would say as far as
reaching into the alumni network i could
talk to us a little bit better than
the career management center just
because i don't i don't use that center
very much
um given my circumstance although i know
that the people that do use it have
extraordinary results with it
um i would say that the alumni network
is
uh alive and well i was considering
doing a uh
i was considering doing a internship
with the
49ers over the summer um before
before the covet thing broke out and the
nfl
kind of slowed down for the summer
months i was considering doing that
as just like an industry that i was
interested in possibly working in after
the army
why not just go get some experience over
the summer and
really the way it happened it wasn't
like i
you know started at the bottom and
talked to some
somebody at the entry level 49ers
position
the guy that's the vp for the 49ers is a
gsb alum
um and somebody was like hey if you're
really interested in
working for the 49ers i'm connected to
this guy
here's here's an introductory email uh
and then why don't you just call him and
you guys can talk about it
and so from me saying that i was wanting
to do that
or to go down that path for the summer
uh to actually talking to the vice
president of the 49ers
was five days maybe um
and so you know i think that the alumni
network is
is definitely alive and well and as long
as
your reputation at the gsb is
is you know one that you would expect it
to be if you're
if you made it in here and you you can
uh you know you don't rub your
classmates the wrong way though there's
all kinds of people it was actually a
classmate of mine that put me in touch
with the vp of the 49ers so
um i would say that the
the career center is a fantastic
resource for anyone
the alumni network is in ever an even
better resource
if you can find the people to tap into
it
and will if i could just add one piece
to something nate said um
in terms of classmates as resources um
so we have for those i'm sure most you
know what slack is but it's a it's a
messaging platform and so we have a
class-wide slack
and i have seen the most
hole-in-the-wall ludicrous outrageous
questions
get asked um most niche thing hey does
anybody know anything about the
dental whatever right uh that get
answered almost instantaneously and it
gets back to that
salad piece a little bit um but
classmates as resources
on top of the cmc which will mentions
and the alumni
are just incredible i mean one that went
out about 30 minutes ago somebody was
asking for a fruit picker
because we have fruit trees on campus
and somebody answered it in 30 seconds
and i
i know that's an off-the-wall example
but particularly as it relates to
professional things hey
does somebody have a a lead in this
space or does somebody have any
industry expertise i have never never
seen one of those questions
fail to get answered um and that's truly
a powerful asset and resource to have
um and it's come come through time and
time again for
for teammates here i'm laughing austin
because when you said a dentist
i was like oh like at least one name
popped into my head right away
so i was like i think i might know who
they might be trying to connect that
person with
um but yeah that is yeah our community
is pretty incredible
um so this question actually for austin
and nico nico
you seem to you might have more direct
experience in austin you might be
looking forward to it
but talking about the recruiting process
um
i mentioned earlier a little bit about
some of the different treks with local
companies
are there any other kind of ways to
explore
industry or pathways that you've seen
either
like opportunities for veterans
specifically
one of the things that i did not utilize
until kovit hit and it really impacted
our ability
to travel because historically the
veterans club did have veteran specific
tracks
like nate mentioned earlier to facebook
and other
bay area companies i
with the work with some members of the
club i was able to reach out to
former alumni who are veterans
and as a club we developed a database
of veteran alumni from stanford gsb
who are willing to have a discussion
or help assist in either networking or
recruiting
for veteran club members
and it i was just so surprised because
it
wasn't seen as an ask it was
they they were asking me what more could
they do
because i think it just really shows
that like as veterans in this community
like
they were here in our shoes before us
and then they were more than happy
to pass it on so like for me what really
helped me
going into my second mba year is that i
was able to have like a stepping stone
with that alumni database
that really allowed me to search and
investigate
the search fund community more
yeah and i'll add on to what nico says
because i'm kind of going through this
process right now
sometimes i feel like a stake and
these companies and recruiters are
hungry dogs out there
salivating um here's the bottom line
people are going to be excited that
you're a veteran
and that's a non-starter right companies
love to hire veterans
uh and then when they see that you're a
veteran that's currently pursuing a
stanford mba
they are over the moon fired up uh and
so i have found
i get emails almost every day from
companies that say hey would you like
would you like to have a coffee chat
with us uh can we'd love to meet you
we'd love you to come to event x y and z
um and it's been incredible uh the
amount
of resources that are just poured into
stanford because
people want stanford mbas on their team
uh
they do it's it's non-negotiable people
are excited
to have a stanford mba people are also
excited to have
event and so when you've got the overlap
between the two
i have found that companies are so
excited to talk to to not only me but to
my classmates and my peers
as well that are vets um and that's huge
so in terms of recruiting resources
there's a lot of goodwill that you have
both as a as a vet
and as a stanford mba that people will
want to pursue you now that's not at the
expense of saying hey you don't have to
do any work to get a job
not what i'm saying at all um but people
actively seeking you out
will be there and looking for you from
any job you can imagine
um across a broad spectrum of industries
um so it's a good place to be as of that
for sure
nice and kind of in stream with this and
this is
something that i'd open up to all of the
panelists
so as we're thinking about what it's
recruiting or maybe it's community
building with alumni or how do we stay
connected with each other
given covid um any observations or
reflections
on your mba experience given like the
global pandemic
yeah i can take this one and i think um
you know especially with all
uh you know with everyone trying to take
their precautions and with different
people having different levels of
uh comfort with uh you know either
meeting in person or meeting in smaller
groups
um i think even in the vets club i think
we're able to do
you know either like smaller group chats
and i know we were trying to initiate
too with like one-on-ones just to get to
know
our classmates even across classes
a lot better and i think that's
something that we've been
really resourceful and like really uh
you know just thinking outside the box
when it comes to that because i think
one of the important things especially
when you come to business school
is building that community and and
having that network and
especially you know for austin and those
nba ones like you know for for you guys
starting out
completely virtual is is very difficult
um and it's hard to build that community
right away without
you know having to force more of those
interactions as opposed to
you know um nate and nico and i when we
were you know in classes and you just
walk by people either like in between
or going to like lunch or like even just
walking out of the residences
and so i think you know a lot of those
smaller group
interactions have been really uh helpful
but also like they
um have helped even like get people a
lot closer as well
and i know i know the best club has been
pretty uh good about that and then
i am also in the pride club and so i
know we've had a good
uh mix of that as well and like just you
know trying to see like and
try to keep and maintain those
connections throughout this uh difficult
time
yeah just to add to that real quick i
think
you know obviously it's not
it's not as as fun as our first year i
mean i can certainly say that
i mean to girls point you could be
walking out of a class and
just randomly sit down at a table and
have lunch with some of your classmates
and i think that that's incredible and
that's one of the things that's great
about this place
i would say that that's still happening
though like i'm still making
relationships with people that i
didn't know uh you know that well
going into my second mba year whether
it's through various classes working on
projects whatever it is
i think that there's still people that
i'm having these conversations with
either over zoom or maybe one-on-one
with coffee staffer's done a good job
about instituting testing for covid so
i think that that makes people feel a
little more comfortable because
everybody's getting tested um
you know and so i think that i've still
had those i mean
i met an mba one actually i met three
nba ones
in the first month that they were here
um
uh for coffee or for a quick lunch just
to to talk to them about the experience
and how to go forward
uh nba one specifically nba one veterans
uh that had reached out to me to ask me
about my experience so i think that
those things are still happening
i think that you're still making those
connections um
you know i would i would be lying to you
if i said it wasn't
uh different with covid i think that we
can all just be honest with ourselves
with that
um but i think that they're still
happening and i think that those deep
relationships are still being formed
thank you and then one more question
before
um i get to claim the last one so
the mba is definitely an investment in
yourself
and so question about like financing it
um if you are taking advantage of yellow
ribbon
um how did you um approach the process
and
who who did you work with like on campus
to like really understand what was going
on
if you needed to do so so any anybody
would like to jump in there
yeah i'll start with that um so the
there is
uh literally a dedicated person
at stanford to walking you through the
gates to get that set up
um so i i uh there are multiple funding
streams that you can take advantage of
uh and what stanford does various from
year to year but as of now they do
support uh yellow ribbon matching for
those with a 100 post 911 gi bill so
that's something that is
uh should be tremendously encouraging um
but uh there are other funding streams
too so i had 100
post 911 gi bill but i'm actually using
um vocational rehab
uh so vr and e to to fund my
uh mba here so it's six and one half
dozen the other in terms of really the
resources and benefits
um but the bottom line here is there is
there is a someone employed by stanford
um that as a vet you have access to and
he literally has a checklist and knows
all the things that you need to do
to get set up with the va team here in
oakland um
to get all that sorted out um and then
behind the scenes they take care of all
that because it's a pretty monumental
task
to secure the funding to pay for the
appropriate things
uh it's it's a crummy process um
but uh the guy named alex here that
handles it at stanford
does all of that so it has really been
super hassle
free if you do qualify for those funding
streams
uh either as the gi bill uh or
or for vrne
any other thoughts on funding
the add-on is that i think what also
makes stanford unique
is that the yellow ribbon that is
available for those who have 100
post 911 gi bill covers
this was a recent thing will if you want
to talk about this more too but
they recently covered the matching
covers all the
tuition and required fees so that is
something that
really makes stanford stand out
among all the other top business schools
and
that is a huge difference i know that
when i was speaking to veterans
because it is not something that you see
in common
you actually captured it perfectly so
thank you for calling that out
and so as we wrap up we're getting close
to the bottom of the hour
so if you could just think back
to like a younger self whether that is
you
as an applicant or you about to
start your first term at the gsb
what advice would you give yourself
yeah so i'll answer this first we'll um
because it's top of mind again i guess
that's what i get for being the baby
on the panel um so i i think first and
foremost
um it's just to remember that excitement
um i remember every
instant of i it's i'll tell a quick fun
story so um i was in a meeting and i i
wasn't allowed to have a cell phone and
in the place where i worked and
uh but somebody had been keeping an eye
on my phone because i was i was hoping
to hear from stanford and somebody
came and grabbed me hey you got a miss
phone call from a 650 number and i you
know
scrambled out of there like a bat out of
hell back to my phone and i had a
voicemail from
uh from kirsten moss the dean of
admissions it was a wednesday morning
so i frantically you know called her
back and she said hey austin this is
kirsten the dean of admissions i'm like
yeah i know who you are you know
you didn't have to tell me that um but
she said hey i just want to let you know
we're excited to welcome you to the
stanford class of 2022.
and i have so that that moment of time
is indelibly etched in my memory
um and so on the days when things are
you know tough or
busy here and uh maybe i lose sight of
that i
just try to remind myself of that moment
in time
of just that pure unfiltered excitement
of knowing that i was going to my dream
school
and so i just try to think about that
from time to time while i'm here
and so i would encourage uh those of you
that that do get that magical phone call
uh really remember and cherish that
moment um
and and take away that energy of that
beautiful moment
and that will propel you quickly through
here um and it's helped me keep that
sense of
awe and excitement as i walk around this
exceptional place with
exceptional people and i'm really glad
for that
i'll answer quickly i think uh i'm a
little bit more of uh
of an introvert i think by uh i mean
everybody that like when you get to the
gsb you feel like
you must be an introvert because
everybody here is so outgoing
um and so uh you know i
but i i do really feel that i'm so much
more of an introvert looking back on it
and i've thought about this a lot
you know since covid's been an issue um
i would say don't be afraid to to reach
out and have those one-on-ones with your
classmates
uh i think that i probably didn't do
that well enough
um you know whether it's just like hey
get quick coffee
with somebody or have lunch with
somebody i just
i don't think that i probably did it
enough and don't be afraid to like
reach out to your classmates and ask for
those opportunities because people are
more than willing to do it
um i think most of you probably just saw
my dog literally
last week i got an invite from one of my
classmates like hey can we go walk our
dogs together
and it's somebody that i haven't really
spent a lot of time with and so
you know i think for me looking back on
it almost toward the
toward the tail end of the journey i
wish i would have done that a little
more i wish i would have
met some more of my classmates
one-on-one i wish i would have connected
um a little bit better
um yeah and then i'll just give my quick
uh plug
and i'm kind of like nate with the the
introvert thing
i definitely wish i could have uh
contacted more people especially now
knowing what has happened with cobit
but i think my big um my big advice is
to
be open to the new experiences that you
have i think
i know everyone does have a path and
like certain goals that they have here
which i would say stick to most of them
but there are also so many other
opportunities out here that you probably
have no idea that are here
not only just in the business school
program but outside in stanford
uh the greater stanford because you do
have access to as well to lectures
within like the law school and if they
have a guest speakers and like medical
school like
you can definitely go across programs
and like take courses across the street
um and there are so many opportunities
here that you know
just keep your eyes open for all that
and like be you know if if you do think
something interests you and like pokes
your
you know like books your interest and
take a class in that or like ask someone
ask one of your classmates about it and
just you know
um take that extra step to learn a
little bit more because you never know
if that's going to be something that
might
as you might want to pursue in the
future and rounding out with the
president of our organization
closing out strong nico
what everyone said is is i resonates
with me 100
um the only thing i would add on is
you know this is you know this is the
time for
you to really develop yourself figure
out who you are who you want to be
and just know that there's going to be a
lot going on
there's going to be classmates wanting
coffee chats
lunches walks there's going to be bbls
there's going to be
afternoon uh lectures uh
combined with networking events and
and it will get overwhelming but you
know it's okay to say no
it's okay to be like i'm not gonna
overextend myself like i want to take it
and
you know test things out because you if
anything you'll have plenty of time
you'll have plenty of time to figure out
what you want to do
don't feel like you have to sign up for
everything
because you can make this experience
whatever you wanted to make it to be
awesome thank you so much to all of our
panelists
both for being here with us today as
well as
your service especially on veterans day
i think this is
so appropriate for us to be able to
share space together
so with everybody who's joined us thank
you for joining us as well
if you have questions please feel free
to contact us at the mba admissions
office i just popped our contact
information into the chat for everyone
we also have a my stanford dot
mba site this is going to be a dashboard
that
based on your interest will help collect
some of the things that
might be of interest to you as well as a
dashboard that'll help
um you in checking you know if you're
applying you know
what is that progress check in what else
can we provide to assist you through
so with that stay safe thank you for
joining us and i hope you have a
wonderful rest of your day